hey gang let's talk about that middle
class famous tour baby
getting bigger and better and it just
keeps her rolling on it's a live
stand-up comedy show plus we played a
little layg with the crowd as I always
say great way to introduce new people to
the show so grab the squad and come out
and see us yeah guys in October we're
going to be in Nashville and then we're
headed up there to Indy then November
we're hitting Atlanta two shows added
there then we're headed to Charlotte we
got Philly Two Sold Out shows there I
apologize you snooze you lose then
December we're hitting Providence and
Boston those are currently sold out but
we're adding new shows stay tuned
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is our you garbage little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out they're good to be classy yeah
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash I'm your host stage Foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here at Aunt Cody's basement she just
got back from the Eagles game okay which
took place about a week ago all right so
she's gonna be hung up for a little bit
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me on a muse this week swinging
a Miss on the Cody gang he is the CEO of
Ru garbage he is an international
businessman he's not to be trifled with
in the Board Room or the bedroom give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan everybody hey
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate you subscribe
on iTunes full video available on
YouTube as you know those numbers are
closing on 100 000 over there then
obviously the greatest website of all
time
www.patreon.com garbage check it the
[ __ ] out oh do us a favor check it out
we love them gang having a nice quick
shout out to our producer X Jordan Air
the magic man makes us all look good he
works the ones and twos he crosses the
t's he dots the eyes give it up for
T-Bone McMuffin Toby McMullen everybody
what up dudes hey T-Bone this is sick we
got a dude who moves tickets like a
football team in this match hey guys a
little bit of star power over Kippy left
me hanging on a Tony looking [ __ ] in
front of Joe he'll pay for that later I
can pay you that gang the long hair
ain't lying we are so excited to have
our incredibly special guests here with
this today for the first time he is a
very funny very successful stand-up
comedian actor and let's not forget
International Superstar gang got a
little star power in the building you
might have seen him in but not limited
to let's go Showtime at the Apollo Comic
View Jimmy Kimmel Live Comedy Central
presents last call with Carson Daly live
at Gotham The Tonight Show with Jay Leno
Comics Unleashed the nightly show with
Larry Wilmore at midnight The Late Show
with James Corden WTF with Mark Aaron
tigerbelly lights out with David Spain
Good Morning America Kelly Clarkson at
tonight's show The View Anastasia Mr
Iglesias Ridiculousness he has multiple
stand-up specials out hachimachi don't
make him angry lights out live from
Seattle coming in hot in his elements
he's also the star of the brand new
movie Easter Sunday and has a brand new
Netflix special out right now that you
gotta check out Live From The Forum in
Los Angeles ladies and gentlemen the one
the only jokoy everybody thank you I
butchered that a little bit oh I loved
everything that was great thank you
buddy thanks for coming man stuff I
didn't know I did
you don't remember live at Gotham
Comic View that wasn't me what are you
talking about oh I loved comic you that
was that's one of my favorite things
yeah yeah that's one of those things
that I I uh yeah I love that that whole
experience was incredible when was that
was like 98. damn it's old school it's
all right yeah I like it give us the
back story where are you from how'd you
grow up lay it all on us uh give us the
origins West Coast kid so where I'm from
is everywhere I was born in Misawa Japan
okay dad was military
uh lived in the Philippines for six
years U.S military US military gotcha
Air Force okay and then we went from
Japan
to Illinois
to uh to the Philippines to see to
Tacoma Washington and then to Las Vegas
Nevada all right and that was all before
what age uh I moved to by by the age of
18. really that was in 18 years yeah but
that's military life that is sure that
was hardcore military life because that
was like you know that's after Vietnam
and you know it was just
yeah it was just it was a tough time
what did he do for the Air Force he was
a cargo uh
I don't know how to say it but he's the
one that ships
he's the one that stalks the cargo
planes for like like War gotcha and if
not war then to supply gases you know
what I mean and my dad is amazing at
packing [ __ ] I'm not gonna lie I'm not
gonna lie man getting sandwiches or one
brown paper bag and packing uh no it's a
road trip putting groceries in a trunk
like it's an art it's an art and uh yeah
and and I I'm not gonna lie I I got that
from it was in his DNA and I'm good at
it too that's pretty was it military
bases that you were on yeah military
bases and then you know when my dad
started earning his stripes he was able
to get extra money to live off base okay
so that was kind of cool but it was also
like the downfall of the family all
right so that's about it on that yeah
go to school on the bases as well
you know like it's so hard to explain to
like my son and this generation of how
difficult that lifestyle is you can
imagine you know it's it's almost like
kind of like a weird propaganda State
you know what I mean it was kind of like
uh you know you watch censored
television you didn't question it you
know you're watching old Wimbledon
matches because you know they had to
make sure that you know things aren't
said and you know wait really on the
court this is coming from the Americans
yeah because you know when you're
overseas you know it you know think
about you're just post-war right now
yeah all right so so it's yeah what
years are we exactly talking about here
uh when I was living in the Philippines
it was like in the 70s you know okay you
know so and then in Japan it was like 71
and 72 so think about that you know and
then my dad's wife is Filipino and you
know so
yeah I I I really remember those times
yeah that's hardcore yeah that's wild
[ __ ] yeah like no one really knows it
like you don't really know it until
you're until you like until like you
speak like right now I didn't really
think about it until now until you
you're asking me these questions but
it's like yeah that that's how it was
back then I remember watching old I
think I watched uh I think her name was
Natalie not not Natalya Navratilova I
think that's her name she was Martina
Navratilova yeah yeah tennis player yeah
and Chris Everett it was an it was a
Wimbledon final I think I watched that
25 times what what they just keep
replaying it this was four years ago
then I would act like he was brand new
every time as a kid because you just
wanted to one you didn't want to watch
what off base people were watching
because you didn't understand it yeah
you know sure and then you want to watch
American TV because you Miss America you
you miss seeing uh uh people that like
that that looks like culture everything
yeah yeah you miss it so but then it's
censored so no Hogan's Heroes knows
three companies company no Dukes of
Hazard nothing like that no it was more
like Sesame Street damn was there Dukes
of Hazzard I no no and where would you
guys eat would you be eating on the base
yeah the base is Fun the base was fun
you know it's everything no no
taxes go to the commissary was fun you
know what I mean because it was like
that's where you got to buy American
food sure you know what I mean it's not
yeah it was cool it was it was cool to
get Chips Ahoy you know especially back
then now everything's like now there's
this thing where everything's opened up
and you know that sure they get the
foods that that we have now that you
know now they have they have a Popeyes
in the Philippines now you know what I
mean so but back when I was a kid they
didn't have McDonald's they didn't have
any of that stuff you ate at the
cafeteria you ate at the base you hit
the base exchange it's like the regular
Air Force guys yeah that's why yeah they
didn't have that stuff they didn't get
that stuff yet and the school like your
Elementary School would be all kids like
other yeah so like that's why I didn't
understand what racism was because yeah
I did it because it was mixed kids you
know I mean like when when Tiger Woods
came onto the scene in 1991 was it like
everyone was going crazy oh my God he's
half asian half black and I'm like yeah
okay so was all my friends yeah that's
all you know half the base so it was
like that's a really good point you know
and then I'm half white half Filipino
it's like yeah I I didn't understand
what that was because we lived in such a
bubble sure you know living on base is a
bubble and and like we we that I I we
just knew about each other's cultures
because we were all it was like a
melting point yeah where did your dad
meet your mom you met him yeah God he
met her overseas and I think in Vietnam
where he was working yeah so so your mom
your mom's Filipino and your dad's white
white yeah gotcha so there you go so
then that probably happened a lot and
that got the mixed culture on the base
yeah damn that's old school man 70s very
old school and yeah and it's just like
you you respect everybody's household
back then yeah you know what I mean and
and yeah so it was a different lifestyle
it's a different culture and how old
were when you guys got to the U.S
um when I finally got to the US I was oh
man
well I lived in Illinois for three years
so from like from like in between all
this yeah from one to four I was in
Illinois and then from four to like 10 I
lived in the Philippines you're in the
Philippines and I remember everything
about the Philippines sure probably not
much of Illinois right one before barely
yeah but you know you weren't America
anymore well I was traumatized if if you
want to get if you want to get deeper do
you want to have fun in this
conversation because we can still live
in a boat yeah I like it
um well my brother you know my that's
when my brother said I have in his
episodes of schizophrenia okay so that
happened in Illinois and I remember all
of that uh vividly older brother my old
eldest brother Robert okay who I never
really talked about okay until just
recently when my book came out gotcha
um so you know now I'm free to talk
about it plus you know we we live in a
time now where people are open about uh
mental health short therapy whereas you
know when I was a kid you get therapy
you're crazy
and you you didn't tell anybody you got
therapy or oh you don't want to tell
anybody that you have someone with
schizophrenia you don't want to say that
yeah they were centering what's
happening I can imagine how they were
with mental health yeah Jesus Christ
imagine having a brother like you know
like it was a I hate I hate even saying
this like it hurts me to even say this
but like I you know when people go you
have any siblings I would just go I have
a sister I have my sister Gemma my
sister rowino and I never say Robert
okay because I knew it just it wasn't
that I was embarrassed of them I loved
Robert I love Robert he's still alive
but uh it's just I didn't know how dark
that was gonna be yeah but it's just uh
you know as a kid you know once you say
you have a brother they want to know
where he lives why is he at school how
old is he and then it then he then it
ends up in the hospital he's got this
did he go to the Philippines with you
guys yeah he did so he was he was with
you and in the house yeah he was and
there was troubling times then too a lot
of cops a lot of uh you know a lot of
black guys not on him military police
too mil yeah and he fought all of them
you know I watched that one movie uh uh
God what was it with uh with Bruce
Willis and uh were the guy's crazy he
had multiple personalities I I and I
apologize
oh God you're you're the Jackal right no
no you're talking about split split and
oh [ __ ] so I watched split and I man I'm
telling you I I I wanted to cry almost
because I understood
well that one that but but
as a guy that has a brother that has
schizophrenia and I've seen what he did
I I know that's a movie depiction of
someone that has schizophrenia like him
throwing somebody against the car and
they fly 25 feet but when you're
five and six and you see your brother
five five six cops that's what you see
yeah you see a Superhero like he was
unbreakable and when he turned when he
turned like that like are you kidding me
my brother was damn [ __ ] you don't
want to talk my brother's tiny like
maybe 140. damn and he'll fight all of
us at the same time and beat the [ __ ]
out of all of us I remember my brother
was getting his ass kicked by these two
cops in my bedroom right and and it just
[ __ ] pound in the back of his head
because he won't put the cuffs on him
and my brother was like he ain't gonna
get those cuffs on me you ain't gonna
get too [ __ ] cops on me I was like
God imagine a kid seeing that where was
this in the Philippines damn no no that
was in Tacoma Washington okay yeah so
they were watching military police were
regular police that was regular police
regular police yeah that was Tacoma F no
Tacoma PD so I was a little older I
think I was like like 12 or so yeah so
when you started getting when did you
come back to the U.S from the
Philippines
when I was like 10 11. and then you were
here until until you left high school
high school then then we just stayed
here yeah and in Tacoma were you guys on
a military base or were you guys off
campus off space okay so now you were
still military military area military
Community a lot of military yeah gotcha
was that public school or was that still
yeah and the cool thing about that is
you went to public school yeah yeah it
was more fun it was more like oh we're
Americans plus regular TV snaps yeah man
we were loving it you probably you got
to go nuts that must be awesome and my
brother had American drugs
it just got worse
[Laughter]
the minute the minute we landed check
this [ __ ] out man the man the minute we
landed in America they didn't have a
house for us yet so they put us in like
this like this motel but a fancier Motel
you know what I mean sure a family of
five to sleep in right in this military
and uh and I'm talking the minute we
landed my brother fights my dad and just
a bunch of cops and just the minute we
landed that's and and did not stop did
not stop so like yeah like but when I
whenever I think about Tacoma I love it
I love Washington and everyone always
asks me you know isn't that your
hometown I go yes but it's also like you
got a lot of memories there yeah yeah I
always talk about the Philippines and I
always talk about Vegas and then kind of
like Tacoma's like this little blur for
me I love it you know I mean but it was
it was a lot of loneliness it was a lot
of that rain just made you depressed
sure yeah Vegas it was a little bit
better yeah because we had money you
know my mom and dad divorced in Tacoma
so yeah it was kind of just my mom
dealing with my brother but no
disrespect to my dad my dad even though
that's not his real son uh that's from
her first marriage uh he yeah we got a
lot going on here yeah yeah man I got a
story man I like it I had no idea yeah
but I will say this man uh and this just
happened recently too like uh when my
brother goes missing my dad finally so
that's awesome that's a good yeah that's
awesome so when you move to Vegas who
did you live with out there
uh my grandma your grandma so uh what
age was that ballpark
um high school so right out of high
school 1989. your parents stepped oh
they were already split up when we moved
to uh he my dad was already moved on to
like another state okay so it's just my
mom basically in Tacoma you guys
basically stayed and your dad moved on
yeah like he he would you know he would
stay you would say for a little bit then
he got a job and then moved out of state
and uh yeah so that's that's where that
tension between my dad and I but you
know my dad and I are best friends now
but that that that part of my life was
really really worked up and all I know
is my mom what she went through and
dealing with my brother and dealing with
that
but every time he's in the hospital
you'll see my dad's signature it goes
and sees him that's good that's awesome
man that's solid so yeah so there we
have it this was fun good night
I'm garbage
it ain't looking good so far
yeah so you go to Vegas and you move in
with your grandparents yeah does your
mom go with you and everybody you're
gonna love this so my mom
you know she she only has after she gets
a divorce she only dates two guys right
this one guy I don't want to say his
name yeah please don't say his name yeah
he's a real dick yeah Randy you suck
yeah he was a dick and um and then she
met this other guy Fred and Fred was the
[ __ ] Brad was a soldier he was you know
he I'm saying was he's still alive by
the way uh he's still married yeah yeah
yeah everyone's dead by the way you guys
I've been running stuck I'm crying over
here yeah yeah yeah so Fred uh came into
our lives in like 1986 or whatever when
I was you know yeah 87 I was in high
school and he was the first guy to throw
my brother on the ground that was the
[ __ ] Fred's six foot four West Virginia
Thor coming in yeah he's six foot four
uh West Virginia uh Mountaineer like for
real Mountaineer you know I mean like I
I I I do a a uh I do this one joke I'm
not gonna do it but uh because that's
cheesy but uh he's he's a mountain man
and uh and I've never seen anyone fight
my brother and Justin I thought we were
getting away from my brother you talk
about Fred he's like he was the greatest
guy I'm like are we take you to the park
yeah on vacation only gotta get my
brother bro because my brother would
always act up with my mom sure so so now
she's dating Fred and we wake up to
kicks on the door
my brother kicks the door open
and here we go right and my brother
starts walking towards Fred and Fred six
foot four man he's in his underwear and
I'm standing by a friend and he goes
Bubba I don't want no trouble Bubba come
on now come on Bubba just calm down but
let's talk let's talk and and Robert
throws a punch and he literally just
grabs him throws them on the ground and
lays on him he goes I'm gonna lay on you
I'm going I'm gonna punch you I ain't
gonna do nothing I'm just gonna lay here
you're gonna get tired I'm just teaching
lay here yeah and he literally laid
there and then he let him back up he
swung another punch did it again and
then he kicked him out of the house
threw a punch and uh and uh he was like
I was like what I'm like I want you to
marry my mom
it was the greatest thing I've ever seen
hey big guy you're in I'll tell you that
Fred Harrison man to this day that's my
man right there but that was still in
Tacoma that was Tacoma so I had to take
us to Vegas so my um
so it does
yeah yeah I was gonna say ocean 13. oh I
hope somebody hit big at the roulette
table or something yeah yeah so so you
ready I'm telling you there's a bright
light at the end of the tunnel the
plague hit real bad that year no I
promise it changes here it changes here
you guys want happiness and here it is
my grandmother gets diagnosed with kids
the good kind the funny kind yeah the
kind that makes you smile right
so all right here we go so she gets
diagnosed with cancer my mom goes hey I
need to be with my mom because they gave
her like six months okay literally so my
mom left us we just met Fred but he just
beat the [ __ ] out of my brother and I
think he's a superhero and my mom was
like I love him I'm going to marry him
of course she is and I want him to and
she leaves to be with my grandma she
goes finish your school year Fred's
going to take care of you guys and I'm
gonna go take care of my my mom and then
you guys come and she literally left us
with this guy that we just met and it
was the greatest it was the best year of
my life man yeah you're hanging out with
a friend at that point and he do Sports
he loves sports he was a Lakers fan I
was a Sonics fan he was a Dodger fan I
was a Mariners fan like it was just like
this this dude his presence and I was
just it was the best time man and yeah
and everything changed and then we moved
to Vegas and that's uh you know I
finally did Fred roll with you
so your mom and Fred are still together
oh yeah they've been together forever
and they're in Vegas they're in Vegas
right now nice okay let's talk about
Adam and Eve sexy pie yeah naughty
naughty time spicing things up in the
bedroom
or the kitchen the living room wherever
you want to get a little freaky dinky
and Adam and Eve can help straighten you
out almost 50 percent off on almost
every item plus free shipping and it
arrives discreetly at your door so your
neighbors don't know what's going on
yeah not like I get my packages from
boners R Us and everybody knows not with
Adam and Eve real shy discreet unless
you want the neighbors to know what's
going on let me open it up yeah man this
ain't my size I like it it's not my bag
baby
shout out to Adam and Eve baby let's go
guys at adamandeve.com get 50 off and
free shipping with code garbage our
listeners will get 50 off almost any
item guys whether you're looking for
something to stick your wee-wee in to
make you feel little better or girls you
need something to shove up there just
use code garbage at check out and you
get 50 off and free packaging all
packages discreet except my package
let's go not only you save money on gas
movies and date nights out Adam and Eve
will continue to save you money and
deliver tons of fun go to adamandeve.com
select any one item use code garbage
this offer is an exclusive offer
specific to this podcast so be sure to
support our show and use code garbage to
get 50 off and free shipping go to
adamandeve.com right now do it yeah how
does your grandmother get to Vegas from
the Philippines if you've not met your
mom in the Philippines yeah my dad
married my mom not my grandma no I'm
aware are you following the [ __ ]
story you think my dad was popping two
Filipino ladies at the same time no but
I assume your grandmother garbage bro
that was in the Philippines right no
that she has her own life she she she
met you know this this other guy okay
and he was a great guy and and yeah they
met and that that was had nothing to do
with military anything they got you yeah
so they met in the Philippines he got a
businessman that was in the Philippines
and then they moved to Vegas your mom
was still in the Philippines and Met
Your Dad yeah gotcha well are they
actually I mean it's a long story she
lived in Utah and then he retired this
whole thing's been a long story what do
you mean yeah I love it and we're only
five minutes
you guys you guys are 55 I have in store
for you Joe's going for the Oscar yeah
you're gonna love this [ __ ] and I'm not
thinking any of you guys
just my mom
and Fred
I don't even think any of these people
exist to be honest with you they don't
this is an animation series I'm working
on it's a one-man show he's working yeah
uh what was the setup like in Vegas what
was the house changing life changing
there was sunlight I finally got to see
some nice weather yeah perfect weather
24-hour basketball everything was 24
hour the economy was booming Steve win
started knocking down buildings everyone
was getting rich you didn't need to go
to college everyone like I had friends
that just we're making six figures and
they were like in their 20s doing ballet
working in the casino just killing
somebody was flying around money was
flying and it was just a good time so
you're just out of high school you moved
to Vegas yep things are things are
popping in Vegas Yes where do you start
working at I start working at the mall
you start working at the mall yeah but I
want to be a comic okay I have no
intention to become a valet attendant or
work the front desk I didn't want any of
those jobs that had security involved
gotcha that I knew I would be people
hungry tough to walk away from yeah yeah
I knew for a fact I would be uh
comfortable and I wouldn't want to leave
sure and content so I always wanted to
be on edge there I I the hardest job to
get was the Mirage ballet that was huge
man I mean people were making like a
quarter of a million dollars Jesus yeah
and they're 20. I I remember I had this
one friend that had uh he bought a house
he had a one of those sea dudes he had a
truck with a a trailer and
22 maybe it's real new money
unloaded yeah yeah exactly I'm like do
you want a shoe cleaner yeah because I
get I get a dollar for every can of shoe
cleaner I sell oh man what was the store
you were working at I I was working at
Foot Locker and then I went to Champs
and I remember my mom traitor yeah yeah
yeah yeah dude I remember crossing the
line I remember when they would try to
push that cleaner on us after you
imported the speakers get the [ __ ] out
of here [ __ ] that and they try and
impress you with the uh the water
repellent put it on a napkin and it
worked on hats and stuff too yeah they
always put on your shoe and your shoe
got wet you're like what the [ __ ] did
you sell me it never [ __ ]
never worked I know and uh what year was
this if you don't mind me asking a Foot
Locker like 89.90 damn that's pretty
prime time to be working on a Footlocker
you got the stripes and everything
uh-huh oh and I had all the J's I was I
was I was J heavy were you was there
no no no I was bad I didn't give a [ __ ]
I just I I wanted to quit and um I just
wanted to I just wanted to do stand-up
and um had you started that time like
even doing mics or anything no no I was
just calling I was calling uh this guy
uh well I was calling all the comedy
clubs like maybe twice a week three
times a week
and uh then it started getting worse and
worse and uh I would lie oh I'm a
comment can I go up I love to open I got
some stuff oh I'm not I don't have a
tape but I'm funny and I would do all
that [ __ ] this is a completely different
time for comedians too yeah just a bit
tapes and stuff like that and I would
call the Riviera Comedy Club back then
that that's what it was actually called
the Riviera comedy club and he was the
one that answered the most he would just
love to talk to me and then at the end
he would just be like nah kid hey man I
can't use you yeah he literally talked
like that he was like yeah kid oh and
then I call him because I knew he'd pick
up
and I just talk and talk and like use
different voices uh well I'm here in
town like if you need me I would just
lie and then finally he would just I
think he just knew it was me all the
time and then what were the voices you
were doing I would do all kinds of voice
I was just a deep voice like like
showing off your impression skills no I
was just trying to get notified I
honestly thought I honestly thought the
guy would be like all right calm down
kid calm down let me see your five
minutes and then and then one time he
talked to me for a long time he goes hey
look kid look I know it's you
I know this isn't really Rodney
Dangerfield he goes uh and he goes he
goes he goes look he goes look kid this
is what you need to do you need to go to
Los Angeles and you need to go work
those stage those rooms until you get a
tape you need tape okay like maybe The
Tonight Show will see you get that tape
once you get that tape submit it to all
the comedy clubs across the country and
that's how you're gonna get booked all
right kid all right and he goes all
right don't call until you do that I go
all right thank you all right bye and I
always tell the story but that's Steve
sharepa it was Steve Sharif oh [ __ ] and
uh and it's so funny because I didn't
know that was Steve schrippa at the time
and uh and it wasn't until later on
until I became a comedian I found out
that that it was Steve sharepa that ran
the Riviera comedy wait you're talking
about Bobby Buckley area yeah yeah yeah
really yeah yeah you ran that for a long
time and then when I started as an actor
and then when I started like he was a
comic wasn't he or he's like yeah yeah
but he was he was really in tight with
Drew Carey and Bobby Slayton and uh you
know Robert Schimmel and like he had
those guys under his belt and I I would
always go there and watch those guys and
um and then uh it wasn't until later
when I started blowing up my manager at
the time knew Steve sharepa and he found
out he goes from Vegas he goes he goes
yeah he goes hey did he used to call the
riv
and and my manager at the time goes yeah
he told me the story where you would
always call the road he goes yeah I
always call me so he goes tell him I
said hi man that's cool dude so yeah
that's a really cool story man what do
you think about it too when I take a
step back it's like it's not like you
were trying to get in like small this
was Las Vegas in the 80s
you were really trying to jump a couple
yeah I was really trying and by the way
Colin Carson like what are you doing
tonight yeah I wanna I wanna open for
Debbie Reynolds tonight yeah yeah if you
don't mind I heard Tom Jones he's an
opener
I just graduated to high school
I
I have to Putlocker wraps up at 7 30. I
could be there by 8 :00 can I open
chapter 9 30 . the mall closes
but uh yeah hi all right I uh yeah and
by the way Vegas was a completely
different ballgame they they weren't
booking anybody it was literally still
Rich Little sure yeah yeah that's what
I'm saying yeah it was they weren't
opening they didn't have open mics now
they have that it was like Wayne Newton
and [ __ ] like that you were trying to
get in there in the mix yeah yeah that's
crazy but they didn't have anything like
that so yeah it was it was hard to tell
Kenny Rogers I'm doing pen before yeah
yeah yeah yeah I I got this masturbation
joke I wonder if anyone's heard it
before
so in Vegas uh were you guys living in a
house where you live in an apartment we
were living in an apartment right behind
Bally's Hotel okay he's a real [ __ ]
who was all in that apartment all of us
the whole Squad the whole Squad you know
it's a lot of people when he says a lot
of them oh it's all of us yeah it was
all of us well your grandmother wasn't
in there with you no no no she was in
the same apartment complex nice but we
were in the two bed we were in the three
bedroom uh two like two streets down
very cool yeah Tupac got shot on the
same street as mine I told you it was
gonna brighten up sounds like a nice
place it's all right though that's a
classy hit what are you talking about
yep Harmon and uh Flamingo
the street it's Harmon and flamingos
where he got shot and we lived off of
Harmon right behind Ellis Island that's
exactly where he got shot
that's a casino like one of those really
shitty it doesn't sound like Ellis
Island yeah it's called Ellis Island
Casino yeah right down the street from
the gulag yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah just brighten it up a little
bit uh one of Steve wins taking over oh
god dude I have a Steve win story for
you
yeah sit here my brother's beating him
up yeah yeah Fred comes in is that kid
you see now [ __ ]
that's good what was the grocery store
that you guys went to when you lived
there uh Vons all right and we're pretty
close and where do you go now
I have it delivered I'm rich
I uh I don't I don't go to groceries
yeah yeah yeah you could probably get it
delivered that's I mean that's not
insane the Amazon's doing that for like
three bucks yeah four people can do that
now literally eat out every day you do
yes
for breakfast this morning I had a bagel
with locks here locks no we went to uh
Tom Tom skins or whatever it's called
it's our favorite when we're in New York
that's where we go for our Bagel it's
amazing tumskins Square bagel
still wearing Bagels who knows
oh it's a Thompson Square I don't know I
thought they were Square basil that
sounds like as you can tell when I said
I go out to eat I only do fine dining
like bagels and cream cheese in Vegas
what was the name of your pizza spot
what was the name of your Chinese spot
uh Villa Pizza nice sounds good and that
was in the mall across from the Foot
Locker that takes a couple minutes away
wait if you were getting like a pie for
the house I said he was from New York
I make the Square Bagels all right yeah
yeah I'm telling you man Square Bagels
and these kind of pizzas are from New
York so I can't be said if you guys were
getting pizza at the house would you
have to go to the mall to get it if I
went what like if you were getting a
pizza it was like pizza night you were
gonna get a pie after the house for the
for the people in the apartment it was
dominoes that's all right respectable
that was the height of dominoes too
though yeah they were really banging
back yeah and then they had to get it to
your house 30 minutes or less yeah would
you hold them to it I turn off all the
lights
give them the wrong address if they were
30 seconds before 30 minutes I was gonna
pretend I wasn't home yet if you see
Tupac you went too far yeah yeah yeah
what about the Chinese spot in Vegas
um the Chinese spot back then was this
place called
oh man I can't remember the name of it
oh yep I do I do remember hold on it's
coming
God it was so good too Sam Woo barbecue
oh that sounds and I'm not even making
it out and they were known for the beef
chow farm with gravy it was phenomenal
that might be the best name that's
pretty classy right there I'll take a
picture of it and send it to you it's
still there
it was still open and they were the
first ones there and now there's a
Chinatown built around it but they were
the first ones and they knew it was
going to be Chinatown too they did I
swear they I remember they built this
big gate like an entrance as if you were
going into China like Chinatown
oh you know what I'm talking about no I
know exactly when in Chinatown yeah they
had this big yeah and all it was was a
commercial area it was like like 10
restaurants it wasn't a Chinatown yeah
yeah and we used to make fun of it like
oh look they're trying to make a
Chinatown it's legit it's the whole
Spring Mountain block now it goes all
the way down for like a couple miles
that's awesome yeah uh what was the
family car and when you guys were in
Vegas uh my mom had a Pontiac Transport
all right yeah yeah not bad yeah it's
pretty hot did you have your own car I
had my Volkswagen Rabbit
with a moon roof do you know what a moon
roof is of course what is it it's when
the window doesn't open up top all right
so does anyone else want to try that's
exactly what a moon roof is
it doesn't retract like a sunroof you
can maybe do the little clip thing and
raise it up
yeah I guess you're right
I'm 100 right but the moon roof had a
handle and you could kind of open it
damn that's old school what color was it
cranked and then it kind of opened up
and that's what made it like a moon roof
because you have to open it wait it
wouldn't go all the way down no no no no
my buddy had a white rabbit no it
wouldn't go all the way down yeah okay
yeah no your buddy had the Cabriolet yes
he did yeah that was that's when you
were Rich that's when you were Rich they
weren't how about uh vacations it was a
family vacation
we're all broke yeah gotcha I remember
going the Magic Mountain on my own dime
Magic Mountain in uh L.A okay but you
were an adult yeah okay but we never
went out did you go by yourself uh I
went with my friend Peter okay yeah
that's all right yeah do you want by
yourself that'd be a tough one yeah
that's yeah I wouldn't have said it
right I would have lied yeah there's a
hundred of us there yeah yeah
I had so many friends
um growing up did you keep batteries in
the refrigerator yes yeah do you still
do that now as you're older no no no but
man those batteries in the refrigerator
I don't think it works no they didn't
yeah it does that doesn't do anything
yeah not at all for crazy people my
parents did the same thing they had them
and they put them in the in the crisper
next to like the lunch meat and stuff
yeah it didn't make any sense but it was
next to the eggs
um next to the eggs uh plastic covers on
the furniture at the house in Vegas no
my mom was anti that which is weird
because all of her friends did did it so
it didn't make sense so maybe I got that
for my mom how about shoes off in the
house of course shoes off in the house
yeah that's a must and everyone should
do that yeah I don't know why that's
even a question
absolutely disgusting hey you remember
why you don't like to take your shoes
off now we keep them on you keep them up
in your apartment now oh not in the
apartment no but am I at home at your
parents house you still keep your shoes
on yeah we keep one in the house okay so
so this is why this is this is why I'm
gonna say this to you go ahead yeah tell
them Joe uh right when I got here I said
can I use your bathroom and what did you
say
yeah it smells I apologize because of
the leak and it's covered in Piss yeah I
wore my shoes in there and when we go to
your parents house yeah
mm-hmm
uh if you were gonna have guests over
for dinner would you make them take
their shoes off of course don't get my
house wow it's my house okay all right
you wouldn't
I think dinner
is a little different because people are
getting dressed up to come over bye-bye
this guy rolls in an iron fist your
place now we come over for dinner you're
having a little dinner party yeah us a
couple other celebrities yeah yeah we
gotta take our shoes off of course yeah
really yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay is
there anybody if somebody was like I'm
not comfortable what would you say okay
okay I'll go like that okay okay
I'm not comfortable okay okay
and then walk away and then have it bye
out of the valley
have a nice day man go get comfortable
yeah go ahead go get comfortable man
yeah
okay all right I like that yeah hmm do
you floss every day yes twice twice a
week not twice twice a day twice a day
twice a day what about what's your
mouthwash situation Listerine blue
really yeah by the way I I'm not I'm
very big on my teeth keep it tight yeah
man floss not not floss between the
teeth down below
where it curves you guys listen to me
when you floss you go down into the gum
line where it starts to curve into a u
that's where the [ __ ] is okay dig that
out okay and you won't need a root canal
are those your original teeth these are
all fake uh because I didn't floss them
he's got it now though
but now I pause because I don't want to
lose these These are [ __ ] expensive
yeah well the ones you get the ones
you're born with are free who cares
about the hosts well when you put 50
jihads in your mouth you gotta take care
of it I gotta take those polish those
tears up every night yeah
porcelain the other ones were both
dumb this is made out of Versace yeah
this is Louis Vuitton Louis Vuitton
teeth oh that's great
um what's the toothbrush electric
regular nope I always buy the same one
it's a soft extra soft Colgate really
yes that's all you need and you don't
need expensive toothbrushes you guys you
don't need electric toothbrushes you
don't need hard bristles medium you need
extra soft and this is how you brush are
you listening you lost all your teeth
what are you talking about God damn it
I'm trying to save teeth
just a little bit more than that
I didn't buy the I didn't buy the teeth
that looked like Chiclets I bought the
teeth that look like real teeth he
didn't have a coupon yeah
they're all molars yeah I don't talk
hey guys flock get a set of abuses I got
this yeah uh yeah floss but when you
brush just put the soft bristles at the
top of your gun line and swoop down down
it's down and then up don't rub across
your gum line because you should brush
away from the gum line I love you will
you brush your teeth in the shower yes
you do you pee in the shower always okay
keep those shoes on yeah
um that's where the piss is
okay whether you keep the toothbrush in
the shower though no yeah I can't
foresee what the math you just did with
the p and the shoes and the the house
yeah I can't foresee you leaving it no
okay but do you know how I lay my brush
down oh no but I liked it oh my God
holder no I don't put in the holder
that's gross because it drips down into
that little holder oh that's bad so what
I do is I take the toothbrush and on the
sink I lay it so the bristles are aiming
down towards the sink so around so it
drips that way that's good yeah you're
welcome it's pretty good and that's free
by the way it's free of charge the
shower at your house we have uh is there
is there is it rain rainfall yeah and
then and then the handheld and then the
handheld yeah is there a glass door or a
curtain yeah
he's got a [ __ ] curtain is the floor
heated in the bathroom or anything not
yet because it's under renovated well
it's not even renovation the whole all
the walls have been knocked down right
now you're getting the place hooked up
huh oh it's getting completely like that
custom designed all custom completely
All Glass by the way
All Glass it's a glass house are you
being serious oh 100 oh that's pretty
sweet my son's room opens completely the
living room has four Glass Walls like
the so it's like inside out yeah and
then the uh that's like Lex Luthor Lexus
I would take my shoes off to go in there
but yeah no kidding and then uh yeah the
living room the dining room and the
front door is All Glass yeah damn
now we're talking yeah when's the last
time you had a massage
oh my God like last week okay you have
somebody you go to regularly you just
kind of jump in wherever or whatever
they come to the house so yeah when I'm
on the road we try and bring them to the
uh like backstage really yeah but I get
them I get them that's pretty sweet and
I get IB bags that's a big thing too
that's real classic yeah that's very
classy they try and offer it to the rest
of the people that are on the on the
crew yeah I want to try it it works yeah
Bert does them all the time yeah it's
it's well look how healthy bird
he's actually looks better I don't know
if you've seen the video I don't care
about what he looks like that [ __ ]
guy is healthy
you know he is right yeah that guy is
[ __ ] healthy have you ever seen him
sick he gets up he he does the ice pass
he does the workouts oh yeah he's a
Russian polar bear yeah he gets checked
up like crazy he's at the doctor like
every two weeks never seen Bert sick
ever
ever the guy is topless on stage and he
wears flip-flops with jeans this guy
should have pneumonia all the time
yeah okay did you have a George Foreman
girl growing up yes yeah well not
growing up after I moved out do you have
one now no okay no he's got a [ __ ]
glass I know I know you're embarrassing
of me I'm aware uh do you ever get a
manicure or a pedicure never a manicure
okay but I do get pedicures and I'll
tell you why because my feet are [ __ ]
gross and I'm not even joking well just
you just got bad feet there's a bad bad
I have a bunion uh that I'm getting
surgery for in uh December uh my
toenails are gross I get I got thick
calluses on both sides of my toes like
yellow they take them down oh they take
away I tell them to shave it do this I
like to scrape the electric shaver yeah
and then they got the the cheese grater
and they use that on my heel I love it I
love it and it's legit a cheese grater
yeah I get them done every every couple
of months just to clean everything up
especially if my feet are going to be
exposed to people yeah you know what I
mean yeah bad news bad news
um know your feet but I know
I have I have a callus on the top of my
toe whoa
how'd you get that
I did I [ __ ] what kind of shoes you
wearing I guess none I guess I stopped
the car but if we did it if we do the
dinner party you're gonna have socks on
right you're not walking all the way up
your feet always socks on you just do
you sleep in your socks no socks off
okay good but always socks on you do
White Sox black socks what do you do
white always white really yeah and they
have to be crew okay they have to be
Polo I like it and all my underwear is
Polo boxers briefs what are you rocking
uh they're whatever this is the boxer
briefs yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah boxer briefly that's rich guy
underwear right there oh yeah I'm
telling you but that can't get those on
a three pack
those come on a hanger the white crew oh
wow that's cool that's cool white and
then white v-neck when I'm wearing
jackets or or sweaters okay Polo v-necks
has to be Polo really I've calculated
how much I spent on pole am I making
this up kitty no she knows every city I
go to I buy probably two or three three
packs and that comes out to like 70
bucks right they're expensive probably
more probably 80 bucks wait why do you
get them when you travel specifically
you don't pay like a fresh tank I don't
really yeah because when I'm on stage I
wanted to Rich guys like fresh teas dude
wait hold on step this back you just
said you don't really pack you just kind
of roll and get some [ __ ] when you get
there
is that what's happening yeah are you
going from town to town just buying
fresh gear and then moving on what do
you burn it before you leave that's the
craziest thing I ever heard that's
awesome that's my publicist right there
yeah am I lying no damn that's what this
show is all about yeah let's [ __ ] go
yo I'm not taking I'm not taking luggage
to Missouri tomorrow
I'll leave my underwear in Kansas City
let the hotel deal with it damn that's
[ __ ] baller yeah we've got we've had
a lot we want to build the stores or no
yeah is that what this show is because
I'm confused listen we've had yes for
sure especially the successful because
you don't want to know where the story
is we celebrate the trash and the
classes yeah so yeah that the big thing
is the is the wins as well well the
stores are are crazy I mean I probably
don't even know what they are but what
are they
do you want my publicist to tell you and
I'll look away or no you tell us
I shut down Pradas shut up really yeah
shut down you're the richest guy ever
met
that's [ __ ] awesome damn
shut him down when do you have time to
do that when you when you when you when
you say you go to yourself I'm done
talking to you wait you guys going to
products in 20 minutes dude Soho Prada
loves me yeah
I didn't know you were born like that I
know you're moving some Dickies but God
damn this guy's shutting them all down
yeah they left the ball Prada all right
there's a big difference between the
[ __ ] I'm not shutting down any m's
you better not big man Lexus pretzies
yeah yeah yeah sorry no more pretzel
bagels
Joe Coy with here
that [ __ ] [ __ ] always gets here
I'm just out front goddamn jokoy [ __ ] oh
damn dude I know that's [ __ ] awesome
I know that's how you're doing it yeah
what kind of shirt is this Jesus purse
but no that's another good one I like
that one too yeah James purse makes good
shirts too yeah yeah
you fly first class to get here true
classic they're a sponsor what
shut down Prodigy 28b you [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh come on
sorry about him [ __ ]
um
[Music]
are you a big foodie like you out to
like really nice restaurants and stuff
remember the beginning of this
conversation
no God damn it I said I eat ow yeah but
is that like a thing for you like you're
like really like no I I do it's not
Arby's okay I will say this I'm I'm very
lazy uh and and uh like I don't have
time to grocery shop every time we do
grocery shop it all goes bad sure I I
end up throwing [ __ ] away buddy I'm on
your side here okay let's [ __ ]
and my son and I don't eat like oh it's
breakfast okay now it's lunch okay now
it's like we eat dinner we snack all day
and then we'll go out like a nice dinner
so it kind of averages out to be the
same thing sure you know I mean it's
like a thousand dollars for that dinner
every night it's like right yeah it's
like [ __ ] with you you've got a 330
per meal I'll take two cows please I
think it's more chop them up no no I'm
joking I was I was [ __ ] I'm sure but
yeah
I got it I was gonna ask you if you use
cruise control all
probably as Tom Cruise driver so
pleasant what I would do
you want a tuxedo
no but I have the best suits yeah all
right suit game what's the suit game how
many we talking I think I have I think
are you sure are people gonna hate me no
no they want to hear this you promise
because I don't talk about this stuff
buddy I'm only doing it because I'm
happy with how much Segura spent on his
birthday dinner oh I crushed that what
the story you told in the beginning what
you went through you deserve every
single thing that you have thank you are
you kidding me no let's all go to Prada
right now I love Tom by the way
shout out to him grumpy and humble Joe
start flexing yeah let's go I got poor
friends to bring in for the bad question
I brought you here for the cash yeah we
just sat here and listened to the whole
Tacoma story let's go lay it on us
man I love this episode this is great
dude how many suits you got talking over
20
yeah probably I shut down Prada one time
you got to make a deposit when you do
that or something like that well if you
don't have enough money
um
it's got to be funny right yeah of
course no but honestly I shut down
product down
on Soho they're all nice to me they're
all of them they love me there they're
great have you ever shut it down and not
bought anything no that's a dick move
you can't shut it down again you can't
be like I'm just looking I left my
wallet in the car I'll be right back I'm
like wild in my spaceship I'll be right
back dip out
damn okay yeah so that that one was fun
because that's when they they bring you
the what they call swatches yeah yeah
yeah the fabrics and so I did I did
three of those okay where they you know
and then the guy comes in the Italian
got the Prada uh Taylor comes in he
measure measures you you pick him up
Prada suits oh I have like I think I
have like
I just bought like three last like two
weeks ago I bought a Nile another nylon
one where are you going what's going on
you got a wedding or something
well no like when you do like a TV show
like when you do like like a like a talk
show or show like a shark bit or
something he does yeah I mean yeah of
course International Superstar I get it
yeah is there any part of your closet
that's motorized no no no no uh-uh how
big is the claw big closet
um this one is this one's gonna be
beautiful the one that we're building a
new one yeah the sneaker collection is
off the charts I assume right probably a
sneaker head right I give them away
though really you know I've been a
secret by the way I want everyone to
know this and you can say this to Tom's
face uh everyone knows I have receipts I
I'm the OG when it comes to snakes like
everyone okay Foot Locker 89. no but you
can even go back to my first special
which was like 15 years ago I'm rocking
I'm rocking uh uh Olympic Jordans Jordan
Ones and then my second special I'm
rocking uh what am I rocking on oh I'm
wearing Bred 11s on the second one and
then the one you were wearing something
really fresh because I remember telling
my girlfriend we were watching it
together and I was like I could never
pull that off they were like uh they
were kind of like cargos but they were
nylon and you had a jean jacket on it
was real simple real clean very nice
it's about 48 Grand yeah that's why you
look good
you're wearing a Hawaiian shirt
pretty sure has stains on it it's a cup
oh man this is fun damn I didn't know if
this is what we were doing yeah what do
you mean I thought I had to tell you
when my life story and then you're gonna
call me garbage oh schizophrenia no
garbage but that we told you it was
lighthearted you blocked into the family
drama happened no no but I appreciate it
no of course it's perfect because it now
shows you know it now shows the win and
the success which is celebrated on the
show yeah
um that's awesome what uh what was the
most expensive dinner because that was
the most expensive one we he's had 52
000 by the way he said that that's a
nice one that's yeah okay yeah all right
I got that for breakfast no we've shut
down we've shut down
you shut the restaurant down yeah we
shut down haven't we or no
that was his birthday I've shut down
birthdays Kippy how long till we can
shut down a restaurant it's got to be
like it's got to be a McDonald's in
Queens and I think I could get us an
hour in the place I think sigura beat me
on the on the restaurant okay okay I
didn't do that that much but
let me guess this you go to you go to a
wedding you go to if you went to a
wedding now for a friend
close friend yeah what are we looking at
in the envelope there
this is what you ask off poor to
successful wedding I mean you got to be
a really close friend I I
you know my closest friends they're
gonna get taken care of the ones I take
care of the most are my that's a rich
God classy rich guy answered
we'll just say that it's the best gift
there but but but my family is who I
spoil the most of course nice like like
and you know and I never talk about I
don't really talk about that I I don't
really don't talk this is so much fun
doing this it feels good to brag about
this [ __ ] yeah but I'd never do it I
never did I really never do it but like
my family like dude it's it's a wrap man
uh like [ __ ] I mean these kids have
grown up together in Hawaii because I'll
I'll fly them all out to Hawaii and
we're talking like 12 kids and and and
they live the life of like they don't
know money in their pocket and they live
it like no this is all this is all your
your family
all of them and no and no parents
it's just me and like another adult so
you'll take all the kids let's go only
the kids really and I've done that for
years and now they're like brothers and
sisters that's like they're so close
because of the vacations it's like and
it's not one week in Hawaii it's
literally three weeks in Hawaii and
and we go hard Uncle Joe's the best I'll
tell you that right now yeah
yeah
for real you gotta do to the family
probably hate you
[ __ ] Joe again you got any Nintendo
switch what do you mean yeah yeah
Uncle Joe bought me the big island what
are we doing and a volcano we all got
our own volcanoes
it's like an episode of Oprah just
handing out volcanoes that's [ __ ]
awesome dude that's so [ __ ] cool man
so cool Joe boy something else I mean
I'm pretty yeah I'm pretty good really
what else hey guys keep going what's
your favorite flavor Gatorade
oh yellow the old school one that's
trashy that he answered the color yeah
but yeah well it should only be a color
because that's not a [ __ ] flavor
they're actually closer to the window
cleaner than they are a drink that's
true they'll get a mirror clean I'm not
gonna lie
um favorite fast food
oh well I don't eat meat anymore so I
still eat the garbage back in the fish
back in the day was Popeyes okay yeah
all right yeah okay I respect it you
like a Jollibee I love a Jollibee like a
jolly big but uh Popeye's hands down
nice yeah you spend a lot do you spend a
lot of time in Hawaii
yeah I mean uh once once a year I'll go
there it's not like three weeks they
gave me my own day there
I broke a record I broke Mariah Carey's
record there most most tickets sold
because my girlfriend's family's from
there and when we go yeah I'm a big
Zippy's fan you like zippies Zippy's is
incredible Zippy's mac salad oh forget
about it yeah l l does a pretty good uh
Maxwell I love it God I love you oh I go
in there and tear it up I'm gonna kiss
your cheeks at the end of this product
there's pee on it for sure yeah somebody
was stepping on me yeah it was you
will you eat a hard-boiled egg in public
always really salt and pepper at the
same time whoa yeah and I'll eat the
yellow part of course even even if I
can't breathe you ever eat the yellow
part it's like cinnamon yeah yeah when
it gets in your throat have you ever had
a trick voicemail where like you go
hello hello hello just kidding I'm not
here leave a message never done that
um you ever have an old-timey photo done
like with your Cowboys yeah it's got an
ex-girlfriend Jennifer okay yeah and I
thought it was the coolest thing
and I look like a [ __ ] ass yeah it's
impossible to look cool and who has that
you or her she was good she wanted to do
it of course of course she was in front
of Footlocker remember it was like a
kiosk okay yeah
she stressed as a cow girl you got the
Foot Locker uniform
she [ __ ] she was hot
and stuff on a nice gown who's the
doctor next to her who has that photo
how are you I don't think oh yeah I
don't know where it is you got it
somewhere probably my mom it's on the
refrigerator
um hmm Saltines are oyster crackers
oyster crackers okay that's a great
question by the way that's something my
mom would make me steal from like like
buffets and [ __ ] yeah the pack of
oysters and they were delicious they're
solid that was a good steal yeah smart
cocktail sauce oh so good they just put
a tiny bit of salt on them oh good dude
and it's like a thicker grain of salt
yeah so it really gives you like a
crunch nice crunch yeah will you take
leftovers from a restaurant now no no
right never no no in fact when someone
does I question them for friends is
there any situation I'm not a leftover
guy any situation from what you've
previously told us now what is there any
situation from what you've previously
just told us yeah that where you would
go out to eat where there's a splitting
of the check situation never never no
never I'll pay you'll pay and do you do
it at the table or do you go to the
bathroom and hand it off no no what if
it's some other heavy hitter no I just I
just look at the waitress and I'll go I
got it I got it or the waiter yeah what
if a Jew no I don't do that no of course
it's like what [ __ ] pay even if it's
you in like another real big dog
yeah I don't care I'll pay you got it
yeah
it's a write-off and I was trying to
force that out yeah
um
any
dumb purchase like not now like from
when you first started making money or
whatever you got a big check in your
life check with my teeth real real yeah
yep that's 75 000 that's pretty cons
that's pretty smart though you invested
it back in yourself yeah you didn't buy
like a fleet of waiver I didn't want to
do it because I couldn't believe how
much it was it was 2500 a tooth and I
needed surgery on the top gum and the
bottom gum they had to like do some kind
of skin graphing and extract like some
metal from my my uh my crown that I had
in there
and uh it came out to like a little
close to like 80 000 for for my first
set and then I had to get a second set
and that was like another chunk chunk
yeah damn that's not a dumb part I
respect that though yeah it's not it's
not wasteful you're putting it back in
yourself you ever have Subway delivered
no okay no but I love Subway you don't
even I even love it more that we found
out that tuna isn't tuna and I still eat
it I'm still gonna get it they make a
mean tuna Hoagie they say that right now
yes to the hoagie and you put four
jalapenos just four
that you know how they usually grab a
handful of sugar no just give me four
you asked for four specifically four
specific it only needs four okay and
then it takes over the tuna because that
tuna is special
am I lying no and that's shredded
lettuce A Little Bit of Swiss cheese or
American or a merit well I put the
cheddar I put the cheddar on there I
respect the move yeah I like the texture
do you put shredded cheese on a sandwich
would you ever do that yes I do yeah
shredded in fact I do that at sub really
yeah the shredded cheddar it's something
people are proud of that yes this guy's
used to be [ __ ] bounced out of there
dude this guy's bonkos
um the butter at your house yeah do you
use butter at the house yes unsalted and
salted is it on the counter in the
refrigerator I leave one on the counter
and the rest in the fridge
this guy's classy yeah telling you right
now this guy really knows what he's
doing what about the uh appliances that
you're getting put in in the in the redo
we talking Viking sub Z we're going that
route yeah sub Z and then it's also
going to be uh wood so that he's gonna
he's gonna actually make it wood the
front of the my the guy my contractor
he's also a carpenter so he's nice so my
guest my guest house everything is
covered in wood can I tell you another
thing I did please fun should I or no
so my ex-wife we're like best friends I
bought her the house in front of my
house
and then we're gonna build a deck and
it's going to be connected to her house
which is in front of mine we yeah so I
have the whole hill in La so she lives
here I live here and then I have a guest
house behind me basketball court pool
this guy's [ __ ] trash
[Laughter]
seriously man Joko is killing it here's
a news flash for you gang oh yeah I love
it baby
that's awesome
any pets yeah two rescues nice yes
Winston heart too all right
I have one that's pretty Niche I've ever
pissed in a bottle yes on a private jet
yes
he told me that was a home run yeah
yes
yeah I did I mean he's all class are you
TSA pre-check yeah sometimes today I was
this time I was TSA pre-check I don't
know what it is with TSA pre-check but
they got me on some kind of weird list
so it doesn't always go through it
doesn't always go through I guess I
gotta go back in and get it done but
yeah this time when I flew over I was
TSA pre-checked probably Global Entry
too I would assume well when we go to
Canada we try and fly private
yeah so we're flying private this week
that's where you're going next you're
going to Canada yeah man
you like cottage cheese
that's a tough one I it's not a choice
if it's no I don't it's not a choice
what's the Mayo at the house is it
Hellman's or is it Miracles helmets Yeah
but here's my thing Sergeant Fred
Harrison likes Miracle Whip because it's
it's it's got a little Zing to it he's
old little yeah yeah I'll let that's
life yeah I'll let that slide for a big
friend Big Fred's all right number one I
don't want to pissed off at me yeah yeah
he'll just lay on you
[Music]
Jesus Christ [ __ ] this up
do you ever ski in jeans
buddy you're 100 class I love it man
[ __ ] Rockstar through and through
ladies and gentlemen Mr Joe Coy special
out on Netflix right now live from The
Forum in Los Angeles right live from the
Los Angeles Forum I [ __ ] it up in the
beginning and I know that I did because
you made me nervous up there
buddy that was awesome thank you oh that
was appreciate it anything else you want
the folks starting to know no that's
that's it that's that's it uh my book
you can get my book at uh any book store
check out the book the movie the movie
oh yeah yeah of course Easter Sunday
Easter Sunday you get that on demand or
or if you're in the Philippines you go
to the theater there you go absolutely
fantastic give me what do you got for
him uh guys we're all over the road
we're adding uh second shows in
Providence in Boston and I think the
second one in Philly is already sold out
sorry we'll see you next time we love
you and we'll see you next week